protesters in belarus show
no signs of losing their resolve to
unseat the man known as europe's last
dictator
massive demonstrations in the capital
city of minsk over the weekend were
peaceful
that's despite a violent response
earlier this month by longtime
president alexander lukashenko chris
livesay has more from minsk
from a savage crackdown to unbridled
resistance
protesters in belarus taking to the
streets by the tens of thousands
demanding president alexander lukashenko
step
down after rigging the elections what's
going to happen to you
we met olga kovalkova the spokeswoman
for the opposition leader
she told us our voice cannot be ignored
everything will be fine with me
but then just this morning unauthorized
protest
landed her and an opposition colleague
in police custody
the last place several dissidents were
ever seen or
heard from again president lucas had
tried to scare all of these people into
staying home
but it's clearly backfired despite
beating them bludgeoning them and
even torturing them today they've given
up
their fear and traded it in for anger
and for courage
as they stare down riot police and a
president of
26 years state media showed lukashenko
circling the protests in a helicopter
saying they flee like rats then later
descending
wearing a bulletproof vest and toting a
rifle
he said he'll consider new elections
over his dead body
not enough to frighten away jana
will the protesters win yes of course i
i'm sure that we will win protesters are
chanting long live
belarus and lukashenko go away the
president of
26 years has clearly lost legitimacy but
the question is
does he realize that and how much longer
is he willing to cling
to power for cbs this morning chris
livesay
minsk belarus